[Applaudissements]
dans les manifestations anti passe on
l'a souvent vu le slogan fausse pandémie
vraie dictature est ce qu'au fond la
pandémie a été vraiment plus grave
qu'une grippe
[Musique]
salut thomas bonjour aurélien alors oui
malgré les mesures qu'on a prises pour
freiner les contaminations l'aco vide a
tué plus de 6 millions de personnes dans
le monde près de 140000 en france c'est
une maladie dont la mortalité annuelle
est aujourd'hui environ cinq fois plus
élevée que celle du sida il y en a qui
disent qu'on comptabilise comme mort du
co vide en fait des décès liés à
d'autres motifs c'est pas vrai les
spécialistes interrogés sont d'ailleurs
formule sur ce point s'il ya un problème
dans le comptage des victimes c'est
plutôt conçu comptabilise les décès liés
à la copie de 19 la seule chose qui soit
vrai mais c'est pas du tout un scoop on
sait que les gens qui meurent de l'aco
vide souffrent généralement de
comorbidité c'est à dire que leur état
de santé général les rend plus
vulnérables à une forme grave mais alors
tu vois par exemple qu'est ce que tu
penses de ces vidéos qui montrent que
les hôpitaux étaient vides au moment où
normalement on était censé être dans un
pic épidémique à l'aller vidéo
d'hôpitaux soi-disant vie dont tu parles
elles ont été faites par des activistes
qui justement ne sont pas allés dans les
unités coville qui était spécialement
aménagée dans d'autres parties de ces
hôpitaux mais allant jusqu'au bout de la
logique
admettons que tout ça soit une mise en
scène les vidéos où on envoie des
malades elles viennent du monde entier
ça voudrait dire que tous les
gouvernements se sont tous entendus pour
mentir à l'ensemble de l'humanité le
tout avec la complicité des personnels
soignants et on n'en saurait rien et
tout ça pour quoi au fond ben je sais
pas par exemple pour mettre en place des
législations d'exception une dictature
sanitaire renforcer le contrôle sur les
populations ou même de tracer donc on
aurait des gouvernements de nature
différente des démocraties des
dictatures qui ne poursuivent pas du
tout le même intérêt mais qui là se
mettrait à à coopérer pour mentir à
leurs propres populations et avec eux la
presse la justice et tous les
contre-pouvoirs leur complot que ça
suppose c'est un complot univers il n'y
a pas d'exemple d'une telle chose dans
l'histoire de l'humanité il ya quand
même plein de vidéos qui montrent que
les gens deviennent magnétique après le
vaccin on pourrait apparemment leur
coller un aimant sur le bras par exemple
alors c'est pas le cas quand on arrive à
faire tenir un petit objet sur un bras
sans rien c'est pas lié à la vaccination
ces liens faits demande d'adhésion liés
à la sueur ou à la propreté de la peau
mais les puces électroniques alors alors
il ya eu environ 11 milliards
d'injection vaccinale depuis le début de
l'année 2021 en face il n'existe pas un
seul cas où on aurait trouvé une micro
puce mais comment on peut être sûr que
des gens meurent du coc vide et non pas
des effets secondaires du vaccin par
exemple j'ai même vu qu'on nous
cacherait des milliers de morts causées
par les campagnes de vaccination qu'est
ce que tu en penses alors ça c'est un
très bon exemple une confusion entre la
notion de corrélation est celle de
causalité situe vacciner un million de
personnes tu vas voir un nombre donné de
gens qui vont mourir par la suite tout
simplement parce qu'il serait mort
vaccination ou non maintenant pour
savoir s'ils sont morts à cause de la
vaccination il faudrait constaté une
anomalie statistique c'est à dire un
nombre de décès supérieur à ce qui était
attendu dans une population et sur une
durée donnée or vaccination or ben c'est
pas du tout ce qu'on a observée jusqu'à
maintenant
[Musique]